[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to black mirror is just about to
release its fit season on Netflix so to
celebrate I thought I'd go back and give
you the top five episodes that you need
to watch before heading into season five
for me these episodes are the standouts
of the show and are the ones that I go
back to time and time again there will
be some spoilers here so if you're not
fully caught up with the show then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to say thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it now sit back relax and let's
get into my top five episodes of black
mirror number five white bear white bear
is an incredible piece of television if
that is more relevant today than it was
upon post release the episode follows a
woman who wakes up to find herself
unaware of her surroundings and
seemingly trapped in a hellish world
where every corner is packed with danger
and death no matter how much she pleads
for help she is ignored by the majority
of people she encounters and eventually
she's led into discovering her true
identity she uncovers that the hell on
earth scenario is all the set up put in
place to torture her after it's revealed
that her and her fiance abducted and
murdered a young girl as punishment
Victoria or protagonist is for still
about the same day over and over again
whilst the public stand by berating her
the episode stays with you long after
the credits have rolled and it perfectly
balances both a feeling of anger and
sympathy towards the character with
white bear we are forced to examine
ourselves and the mob mentality that has
become prevalent with social media these
days and how in punishing monsters we
must ensure that we don't become them
ourselves
why bear is fantastic and definitely
deserves a reward the DJ hang the DJ is
an episode dedicated fully to online
dating and it really knocks her out of
the park from the earth with characters
both struggling to find the one due to
their fixation on statistic matches and
the apparent algorithm that will find
them the perfect
the episode is a clever examination of
social situations and toxic
relationships that neither people
refused to leave due to disapproval by
something they view as higher than they
are this of course can be applied to
parents social circles and more and
metaphorically it works on a lot of
levels similar to white bear this
episode has an amazing twist with the
reveal being that this has all been a
simulation carried out by the dating app
in advance to work out whether the
people it is pairing are actually
capable of being a match
unlike most black Mara episodes this one
has a happy ending that helped it stand
out from the rest and it definitely
deserves your attention number three
Bandersnatch
I can see Bandersnatch dividing a lot of
people who click this video but
personally I think it's a masterpiece
the episode is unlike any other and it
puts the viewer in the position of the
player as they navigate a world filled
with choices that hold many different
consequences and it showcases how one
decision can branch off into multiple
paths those who believe in things like
string theory and the multiverse will
lap this up as there are several amazing
sequences in there that really can alter
the perception of how you look at the
world your experience of this episode
truly relies on your choices and that's
what makes it so brilliant some will
love it others will hate it and it's
purely down to the choices that they
make which can be viewed as a metaphor
for life
Bandersnatch is brilliant and though
many may not like it they have to
respect how unique and ingenious it was
upon its arrival number 2
San Juan a pair of similar to hang the
DJ San Juan apparel stands out from the
other episodes in the series because it
has a happy ending the episode is about
two people who perhaps have had regrets
in their life but now have the
opportunity to change them and live the
way that they should have this episode
offers up a refreshing heartwarming take
on what could hopefully happen to our
consciousness upon debt and how heaven
may indeed be a place on earth depending
on how much you look forward to spending
the rest of your life in a server form
in the end we discover this is all a
simulation
however that twist seems inconsequential
with the true drive of the episode
coming from the relationship that is
formed between the two protagonists
sanjuana pero I hope I pronounced that
right I'm really sorry bhavan is a
heartwarming tale at
definitely deserves a revisit as it's
one of the best episodes of television
ever made and finally taking the number
one spot for me is white Christmas this
easily stands head and shoulders above
the other festive episodes and everyone
in it knocks it out of the park
especially Jon Hamm the anthology is
built around three into woven stories
that all end up complementing one
another and work together perfectly to
provide an extremely haunting narrative
that will stay with you long after you
finish watching it packing not only
amazing technology moments but also
focusing on our culture of muting and
blocking people that we don't agree with
this devastating look at the future and
what we could have in store for us if we
continue to advance in the way that we
have been doing so online is truly
haunting this is simply outstanding
television and the harrowing twist at
the end may believe many feeling that
there is no way we can have a bright
future overall white Christmas is
incredible and that's why it ranks
number one on our list obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on my list as
well as your own do you agree with me is
there an episode that should have been
included or did I get it all wrong
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you stay locked to the
channel for my breakdown of all the
episodes in season 5 which will be
coming later in the week as many of you
know I'm currently away at the moment
but I'll be back just in time for this
so make sure you keep an eye out for my
upcoming ending explain videos this is
the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]